non effectués dans l'air d'accord fallu
comme une insulte oui énormément de gens
ont voté hier notamment et ben on
attendait plus mais xavier dupont
il a dit je pense non seulement qu'elle
le peut mais le doigt pour l'avenir de
la france et le bonheur des français je
pense que elle s'est hissée au premier
tour de façon indiscutable à la tête de
l'opposition à maquereau et là il ya
deux mains pour voir les conséquences de
50 sa politique puisque 2 1 est une des
villes les plus pauvres de france eh
bien j'espère qu'il en sera ressorti
avec la conscience que sa politique a
fait énormément de mal c'est comme
l'immigration et vous faites venir tout
le monde y en a qui travaillent dans le
pays qui s'intègre à ok va venir tout le
monde si si ça vous savez très bien
qu'il faut y en a pas qui font des corps
n'est il est vrai pas un dixième dans
leur pays nous on ferait à 10 m qu'est
ce qu'ils font ici dans le pays
moi je me suis dit effectivement qu'on
avait peut-être sous-estimé le score des
manuels le père manuel mata du mali le
pen
dans le midi quand on décrit qu'en mai
tous les jours
et vous connais pas en dessous merci
beaucoup
l'élection n'est pas jouée et je veux
très bien sûr marine le pen parce que je
crois que le choix est existentiel pour
la france terreur je lui disais un jour
je m'accrochais d'avoir voulu faire le
vide entre lui et les extrêmes donc moi
je vais voter pour lui sans état d'âme
sa position et de toute façon que quand
vous perdez quand vous êtes éliminé une
demi finale vous n'arriverez pas la
finale on a marqué le parti trop à
droite et il y avait de la concurrence à
droite donc ça ne servait pas à grand
chose on aurait mieux fait de rester sur
les mines
glisse notre famille politique a
toujours été et reste un adversaire
déterminé du rassemblement national
aucune voix ne peut se porter sur marine
le pen c'est 7 millions de remboursement
manquent pour boucler le budget de la
campagne
les républicains ne peuvent pas faire
face à ses dépenses
je chili endettés personnellement à
hauteur de 5 millions d'euros déjà je
peux pleurer pour une candidate qu'a
proposé de revenir sur le droit du sol
il paraît qu'elle a 10 millions d'euros
de patrimoine donc ça lui laisse une
réserve pour payer les 5 millions qui
lui manque c'est lorsque vous dites le
régisseur bah écoute et elle se
débrouille en moi je vais pas pleurer
pour ça c'est pour cela que je lance ce
matin un appel national
c'est anne hidalgo qui s'en est vraiment
pris plein la figure pensez à vous
couvrir demain matin il prévoit des
températures comprises entre le score
d'hidalgo pécresse donc des températures
très basses 1 vous l'avez compris et
d'algos à 1 90 % c'est le prix de
l'essence avait tué l'air au passage
j'ai envie de vous dire que l air c tu
es tout seul
est d'ailleurs regardez ça ne vaut pas
que pour les républicains on a une
lourde ardoise un lourd déficit dans la
campagne plus de 5 millions d'euros et
en particulier immédiatement 2 millions
d'euros à trouver sous cinq semaines
c'est pour ça que dès hier soir avec
yannick jadot nous avons lancé cet appel
soutenir l'écologie point fr c'est
évidemment jadot qui s'est planté laisse
aussi la direction du parti les
responsabilités sont largement partagées
avec vraiment une erreur de choix
politiques massives
les yeux dans les yeux il fallait voter
jean luc mélenchon c'était le vote utile
mais j'ai noté jean luc mélenchon vous
avez voté ajouté jean-luc mélenchon
était à l'estomac pourquoi y'a des gens
qui parce que pour pourquoi mais parce
que non j'ai voté jean luc mélenchon
mais parce que mais comme je l'étais je
me suis jamais caché mois de ça je vous
donnais une citation d'un cacique de l
air cette citation que je ne connaissais
pas ces chiens qui vous caresse vous
donne des puces imaginez ça veut dire si
nicolas sarkozy est trop gentil avec
emmanuel macron ça ne pourrait pas être
terrible pour lui